[Musik]
kooperation zwischen dem bundesheer und
dem verein lichtleistung für ist einfach
nicht wegzudenken
was mich natürlich besonders freut ist
dass sich nicht nur die karte in den
dienst der guten sache stellt und von
licht ins dunkel sondern dass es einfach
unglaublich viele spitzensportler gibt
die sich auch für licht ins dunkel
einsetzen und das ist für mich einfach
auch so faszinierend wenn ich dann immer
auch sehen welche spitzensportler auch
alle weil ich weil ich für so viele
mitmachen und welche spitzensportler
beim bundesheer beim österreichischen
sind also denkt dass das ein ganz toller
initiative ist und man hätte jedes jahr
mit wie vielen projekten da die ganze
kampagne preis und das ist wirklich ganz
toll jetzt bin ich froh dass sie da
einen gang weiter zu leisten haben unser
geld reinkommt und die ganzen projekte
geführt menschen zu helfen die hilfe
brauchen die geld benötigen gerade jetzt
in der weihnachtszeit und das ist für
mich licht ins dunkel und die probieren
eben diesen leuten zu helfen
die weihnachtszeit sondern schöneren
zeit zum ausruhen
[Musik]
es geht um exponate genannten geld nicht
kaufen kann und ich glaube das sind
einfach auch die wichtigen geschichten
und die tollen geschichten über licht in
das dunkel auch passieren dass es zwar
um viel geld geht das wir brauchen für
menschen damit wie man den alltag
erleichtern können und selbst kann man
mit steigern hierbei exponaten die man
sonst für geld nicht bekommen würde
[Musik]
ich bin fast sicher nervös ist sehr sehr
cooles studie später sollte auch mein
erstes mal fürs erste also finanziell
sei gespannt wie das abfahren
wir sind generell werfen aber scheint es
ist total super wie wir uns da
unterstützen gerne mit verschiedenen
aktionen und licht ins dunkel ist habe
einer der letzten möglichkeiten nur wie
ich direkt jemandem helfen